travellers coming to the US for visit or
to stay will have to provide a lot more
personal information before getting in
we're getting our first look tonight at
a new Trump administration rule
requiring data on social media use past
immigration history and family
connections to terrorism
of course monitor it Jetson is at the
State Department tonight with our story
rich the government wants more
information for those looking to come to
the United States another step in
implementing a campaign promise I call
it extreme extreme vetting the Trump
administration published a proposal
today that would require those applying
for a visa to divulge their social media
identifiers like Facebook names and
Twitter handles that they've used for
the past five years a State Department
official says there will be no requests
for the passwords to those accounts the
proposal also would require five years
of phone numbers email addresses
international travel whether they've
been deported or removed from any
country and if family members have been
involved in terrorist activities one
security expert points out these new
standards could create much more
bureaucratic paperwork and possibly lead
to delays in issuing visas there's
information available in social media
profiles that can be helpful in
determining whether or not somebody
should be coming to the United States on
the other hand knowing that the US
government's gonna look at their social
media profiles maybe for people who have
ill intentions we'll use that the ACLU
says the proposal will infringe on the
rights of immigrants and u.s. citizens
by chilling freedom of speech and
Association State Department officials
say they expect this will affect nearly
15 million travelers and only those
applying for a visa to enter the United
States millions of visitors from dozens
of countries can and do come to the u.s.
without a visa the US has a deal with
these countries their citizens can
travel to the US for 90 days for tourism
or business and there's no need to go
through this application and apply for a
visa that same program also allows
Americans to show up to countries
without a visa and just their passports
these new standards aren't final yet
this begins a 60-day period where
anybody can issue a comment the federal
government will then consider those
comments maybe make changes and then
implement these new standards over the
next few months
Richardson force at the State Department
thank you rich